Good morning. So today we do Greek
civilization. We are focusing on Homer
who wrote the Iliad in the Odyssey.
A couple years ago I taught the great
books. So we read the Bible, uh Dante,
um Paradise Lost, the Iliad and the
Odyssey. And believe it or not, the
students favorite book was the Iliad.
And this was written maybe 3,000 years
ago by this Greek man living in a
different time, different culture. Even
today, Chinese teenagers
think he's wonderful. Okay. So, Homer
is, I believe, the big bang of Greek
civilization. All right. So, let us
summarize where we are. Okay. Let's
review where we are. Okay. So remember
that in the beginning you have this city
emerge in a major trade route
and it occupies a major river
and over time what will happen is that
as the city expands it will create
colonies along the river and this will
create warfare among the city states
because they're trying to control trade.
Okay. And this leads to what we call
open
cooperative
competition. And as I keep on saying
this is a system that will lead to
tremendous innovation.
Okay. And this is what happened in
China, in Mesopotamia and in Egypt. But
then over time what will happen is that
an empire will emerge and this will
create a bureaucracy.
Okay. Now bureaucracy has three major
characteristics. The first is
centralization.
And because of centralization, you have
now have a monopoly and so you have a
decrease in competition which means that
the society is no longer innovative.
Okay. Second is you have censorship
meaning that um no people are no longer
free to express what they want. All
information is centralized. The third is
writing
as propaganda.
So writing is a system of control as
opposed to a system of knowledge
creation
or self-expression. Okay. So these are
the three characteristics of an empire
and um this is true for all empires.
This is true for manian Greece.
So remember Minanian Greece is the
empire that ruled the AGNC during the
Bronze Age. What's interesting though is
when the branches collapsed,
this system allowed for massive
innovation
which gave us the Greeks. Okay, so let
me explain why. First of all, you now
have centralization, but you now have
something called the polus.
So you basically have a return to the
system of open warfare. The polus means
citystate
in Greek and it gives us the word
politics. Why? Because these polices
were at war with each other always and
because every citizen
um had to risk his life in a war. Every
citizen had the right to speak. Okay.
So before every [clears throat] decision
was made, all the citizens could debate.
And so as a citizen, you were required
to speak in front of others.
And as a result, you even though you
could be a farmer, you had to educate
yourself. You had to gain knowledge. You
had to learn the art of speaking, what
we call rhetoric.
And this allowed for
massive education
and innovation in Greece.
Um the polist because everyone had to
learn they had to change the writing
system from one of propaganda to one of
knowledge seeking. So they changed their
writing system. So during the mian age
the wring system is called linear B.
And line B um is a hard system to learn.
But that's the point.
They want the writing system to be hard
to learn because then only the elite can
learn it. And that's what differentiates
the elite from the people, right? But
now that everyone has to learn, you need
you need a more efficient writing
system. And so they incorporated they
created a new system called the
alphabet.
which is the same system [clears throat]
we use today because it's so effective.
Okay, so let me explain what the
alphabet is. [clears throat] All right,
so in the beginning when we first start
to write, we had pictograms. Okay, so
this is the sun. This is the moon. Okay,
sun and moon. As you can see,
these are just pictures of words. Okay,
that's the first step. But then people
realize, you know what? We we actually
don't have to write down. We actually
don't have to draw down draw out the
pictures. We can just use symbols. Okay.
So now you use symbols like maybe an O
and this. Okay. This is now becomes a
sun moon.
And then people realize you know what
there actually a lot of words we cannot
draw out. But if we make the symbol
representing a sound as opposed to an
idea, that' be a lot more efficient,
right? And so now um you can create new
words. This is the word now for monsoon
because all you're doing is you're
adding two sounds together. Okay? And
this is what I call a syllary. Okay? So
linear B was a syllary.
And um the Chinese system is what I call
an idoggram.
idiogram. Okay. So it's it's not
representing sounds, it's representing
ideas. All right? And then people
realize, you know what,
for it to be most efficient, to be most
flexible, to be most versatile, we can
just have the symbol represent a part of
a sound. Okay? So rather than a complete
sound, just a part of a sound.
So now this becomes
M. This becomes S. Okay. And so you now
get the word sum.
And this is where we get alphabet from.
What the Greeks did was they added
vowels to the system.
Okay. And this is the most efficient
writing system in the world. It's really
easy to learn as you know uh from
English class as opposed to Chinese
which is very hard to learn. Okay. So
now you have the alphabet which
increases literacy and learning
throughout the Greek world
for entertainment. What they did was
they invited bars, poets to come and
give recital to talk about the legends
of the past and this gave rise to the
most famous
poet of that time named Homer and we
will discuss Homer today. Okay. And so
in a in a centralized system, Homer
could not have have arisen because Homer
would have would have been a
propagandist. But now in this
decentralized system where everyone is
looking for entertainment for knowledge
Homer can arise and Homer will be the
greatest poet of Greek civilization and
he's considered to be the father of
Greek civilization. Okay so we will
discuss Homer today and Homer is famous
because he wrote two books the Iliad and
the Odyssey actually he didn't write the
books he recited the the poetry and then
his students wrote it down because he
himself was illiterate and we also think
he was blind. Okay, so the Iliad and the
Odyssey are about the Trojan War. Okay,
so let me explain to you what the Trojan
War
is.
[snorts]
Okay, so um from last class you know
that uh Troy was the center of the
world. It was the heart and center of
global trade and that's why pirates kept
on raiding Troy. Okay. Now, as you also
know, facts become stories and stories
become exaggerated over time and that's
what gave us the legend of the Trojan
War. Okay. So, let's go over the um
basic outline. So, there are uh the gods
of Inman Olympus. The king god of course
is Zeus.
And the three goddesses are Hera,
who is the queen god. They are Athena,
the goddess of wisdom, and Aphrodite.
who is the goddess of love. Okay. Hero
is the queen, the mother. Athena and
Aphrodite are the daughter of Zeus. So,
it's one big family.
One day, um they discover a golden apple
on Mount Olympus. And the golden apple
says to the most beautiful in the world.
So, of course, all three believe it must
be mine. And so they fight and they
fight and they fight. And Zeus
is going crazy because they won't stop
fighting. So Zeus has an idea. He will
have a contest.
And on this contest, the golden apple
will be awarded to one of the three.
Okay. But now he needs to find someone
stupid enough to be the judge. And he
finds this person named Paris. And Paris
is a prince of Troy.
And so Paris meets the three goddesses
and of course each goddess is trying to
bribe Paris.
So Paris says Paris if you pick me
I will give you a kingdom. I will make
you a king. And Paris like that's a
really attractive offer. Okay. Then
Athena says hey if you pick me I will
give you all the wisdom in the world.
you will be the wisest man in the world.
And Paris like, okay, that sounds cool.
Sure. And then Aphrodite says,
I'm going to give you the hottest girl
in the world. And Paris is like, yes,
that's what I want, man. Okay. So, he
marries Helen.
Um, this this this may sound strange to
you. like why would you give up power
and wisdom for you know sex and so I was
talking to my wife about this cuz I I
didn't understand Paris's choice right
and she said of course you pick Helen
because what matters to guys is status
face right [snorts] you're a king but
there are lots of other kings you have
wisdom but like who knows you have
wisdom right but hey if you're walking
around the world with like the hottest
girl in the
you feel good about yourself. Okay, so
of course you pick Helen. So there you
go. My my wife knows more than I do. All
right, but anyway, so now
this is a problem because now Hera and
Athena are pissed off and they want
revenge. In fact, they're so pissed off
they decide they're going to destroy not
just Paris, but the entire Trojan
people.
Okay, they're going to wipe out Troy
from the face of the earth. They want
revenge. Another problem is at this time
Helen is married to Menalos who is the
king of Sparta and his brother is
Agammanon who is the king of Argos and
Spartan Argos are the two most powerful
places in Greece. So Agamman is the king
of kings. He is the king of mine Greece.
And so they organize this huge army to
attack Troy to
retrieve Helen. Okay.
Um and this will go on for 10 years,
this battle in Troy. And this will give
rise to many legends that Homer will use
to entertain the Greek people after the
fall of the Minian Empire. Two of the
most famous heroes of this time and
there are like hundreds, okay, are
Achilles
and and Odysius. Odysius is known for
being the wisest of the Greeks, the
greatest strategist. Achilles is known
for being the bravest warrior. Okay. Um,
Odysius will come up with the idea of
the Trojan horse, which is what ends the
war. Because, as you know, what will
happen is the Greeks will sneak inside a
horse, a wooden horse, pretend that it's
a gift to the Trojans. The Trojans will
take the horse inside the city. The
Greeks will sneak out at night and kill
everyone. Okay. All right. So, that's
the um
story of the Trojan War.
What Homer will do is he will take this
epic, okay, this legend and turn it into
a great story. He does not tell the
whole story. He only tells a part of the
story. He tells a story of the battle
between Achilles and Eggman. Okay, so
let's go over the plot of the Iliad.
Okay, the Iliad.
All right. So the story begins like
this.
Egay Menon
has arrived in Troy with his entire
army. But Troy is a walled city and
these guys are pirates. So they cannot
uh destroy Troy. So what they what they
do is well they're pirates. So they go
and they go and raid other islands that
are allies of Troy. And what they do is
they capture booty which includes
beautiful young girls. Okay? And they
have these girls as sex slaves. Now the
custom of war is that if a girl belongs
to a powerful family, that family can
choose to ransom her back and you have
to give her back. Okay. Now it turns out
that Agameanon likes his girl, but she's
she's the daughter of a powerful priest.
And the priest says, "Give me back my
girl and I'll give you a lot of money."
And man says, "No, I like her and I'm
lonely, so screw off." So this priest
gets angry and prays to Apollo and
Apollo unleashes a plague on the Greeks
and everyone's dying. Okay? And so
Achilles
discovers what's happened and he
confronts Agamenon in a war council and
he says, "Ega Manon, you have to give
the girl back or else we're all going to
die here." And says, "Fine, I will give
her back, but only in the condition that
I take your girl." And of course,
Achilles is pissed off. He's like,
"That's not fair." And like, "Too bad.
I'm king." And so, Achilles says, "Fine,
but I will never fight for you ever
again. I'm going to let the Trojans
destroy you
here. I'm going to I'm the greatest war
in the world. I'm going to sit back and
I'm let the Trojans destroy you. Okay.
So after after that meeting, Achilles
goes to his mother who's a goddess. Her
name is Fetus and she's a river goddess.
And and Achilles says to Fadius,
"Listen, mother, could you help me out?
Could you tell Zeus to help the
Trojans?" The reason why is I want the
Greeks to lose so that they beg me to
save them.
I came to Troy to be a hero.
So
let the Trojans win and then I'll come
and save the Greeks and I'll be a great
hero. So that's what Fetus does. And
Hector,
who is the prince of Troy, okay, he's
brother to Paris. He discovers that
Achilles is absent from the battlefield.
So he leads the Trojans against the
Greeks and they're destroying the
Greeks. They're at the point where sorry
at the point where they've almost
reached the Greek ships and they want to
burn down the Greek ships because if
they do that the Greeks cannot resupply
themselves and they will all die in
Troy. And so at this point Odysius and
the other Greeks say to Eggmanon, "You
know what? We need Achilles. Please
please get Achilles back into the
battlefield." And says, "Fine. Tell him
this. Tell him I will give him my
daughter in marriage. I will give him
all the treasure in the world if he
comes and fights for us. So Adysius and
the Greeks go to Achilles and says,
"Please, please, please help us." And
Achilles says, "Nope." Why? Because Agon
is not here. Where's Agame, man? I don't
need his daughter. I don't need all this
money in the world. I'm going to die
anyway in battle. So screw off. Okay. So
now
Achilles and Eggman are stuck because
Achilles wants Eggman to apologize, but
Eggman doesn't want to lose face. So
there's a real threat that the Trojans
will destroy the entire Greek army.
Okay? And they're about to reach the
ships and burn down the ships. And
Achilles is watching this and he's like,
"Why aren't the Greeks coming and
begging me again?" Okay? He wants the
Greeks to constantly beg him so he can
say no. And the Greeks and the Greeks
are like, "We know that. So we're not
we're not going to come." So then what
happens is Achilles, he's so nervous
that he sends Petroles, who is his
lieutenant, to go talk to the Greeks and
say, "Hey man, what's going on? Do you
need Achilles help?" And the Greeks say
to him, Petroas,
we know Achilles, he's got this terrible
temper. He's not going to come save us,
but maybe you can save us, Petroles. And
chocolate says, "Yes, I can be the hero
now." So he runs back to Achilles and
says, "Achilles, you We're all
going to die here. Let me go fight." And
Achilles is like, "Fine, you you can go
fight, but only the condition that you
just save the ships and you do not push
the Trojans back to Troy." Okay, that's
my glory. Do not steal my glory. So, of
course, what Procus does is he tries to
win all the glory for himself. He forces
a duel between himself and Hector and
Hector kills Petetrois. Now Achilles is
pissed off and and Achilles is like
screw this. I'm going to go kill Hector.
Okay, so now Eggmanon and Achilles are
best friends because they both want to
kill Hector. Achilles duels Hector,
kills him, and he is now the greatest
warrior in the world. He's proven
himself to be greatest hero in the
world. He's saved the Greeks. He's
killed Hector. He's adventurous friend
Petolis. He should be the happiest man
in the world, right?
And this is the genius homework. He now
falls into a deep depression. He
mutilates Hector's body. He ties
Hector's body to his chariot and rides
around the city of Troy. And all the
Trojans are screaming in horror. The
gods are like, "This is disgusting,
man." The Greeks are like, "No, man.
This is a war crime. We don't want to
get involved. Okay. Achilles is going
crazy. He can't sleep. He can't eat. All
he can do is mutilate Hector's body. All
right. So now, so now the gods are
watching this and saying, "You know
what? Um, we shouldn't allow this
because this is a war crime and Hector
was always um a good subject. So let's
broker a piece between Achilles and Pry
who is the father of Hector. Okay,
because in this world it's important to
bury the dead because only by burying
the dead can they find eternal peace.
Okay, so Prime wants wants a body back.
So Prime himself cannot sleep and both
Achilles and Prime agree to this deal.
The gods send Prime into Achilles tent
and Achilles is busy. Okay, Achilles is
distracted and Prime is sitting next to
him. And at this point, what Prime can
do is take a dagger and stab Achilles in
the neck and avenge his son, right?
What he does instead is he kneels down
before
Achilles and kisses his hand. He submits
himself before Achilles.
And Achilles is so
aed by this that he recognizes that Pry
is the greater hero. That Pry has more
courage than he does. And now Achilles
submits to Pryam.
And the two forgive each other and
weep together. And this is how the idiot
ends. Okay, this is a story
that tells us that the real battlefield
is not out there in the shores of Troy.
The real battle is inside our human
heart. Okay. Why does a Achilles fall
into depression? Because he himself
knows he's he's the one guilty for
killing of Petetrois.
Maybe it was Hector who
killed Hecles, but it was Achilles who
made it possible. Why? Because number
one, Achilles didn't have to get in a
stupid fight with a mountain. Okay.
Number two is when the Greeks came came
to beg, Achilles could have could have
said yes. Okay. And then number three is
Achilles did not have to send Metropolis
into battle.
So Achilles know in his heart that he
was guilty and as such he could not
forgive himself
and so he fell into depression and so
pry by forgiving Achilles allow Achilles
to forgive himself.
Okay so it's it's a problem of
forgiveness and this is the hardest
problem in human society. How do you
forgive those who've done wrong to you?
And how do you forgive yourself for
doing wrong unto others? This is the
hardest problem in human society. If you
if you can solve this problem, you you
can now create a great civilization.
That's what Homer did. Okay? Homer
showed us that this is the greatest
problem in the human heart. And when we
forgive each other, we make the world a
new. We rejuvenate the world. We change
the world from one of the destruction
into one of vitality. Okay. Pry him by
sacrificing himself by having the
courage to forgive Achilles.
Change the destiny of himself and his
son Hector because Achilles
gave Hector back and told Pam, "Not only
will I give your son back, but I will
make sure that you have enough time to
ensure a proper funeral for Hector."
Achilles himself will ensure the Greeks
will not attack Troy during the funeral.
Okay. And that's the beauty power of
the Iliad. It is the most shocking
ending ever. It's the most beautiful,
the most poignant, the most tragic
ending ever.
Even today, we cannot match it. So the
question now is how is it that home and
the Greeks had such wisdom and today
we don't
and the answer is their minds were
different back then than they are today.
Okay. So let me explain why.
[snorts]
Okay. So you know from psychology that
we have two hemispheres in the brain.
Okay. A right hemisphere and a left
hemisphere. The right hemisphere is a
creative, emotional,
caring hemisphere. The left is the
logical, analytical, utitarian
hemisphere. Okay? So, right does art,
maybe left does math. Okay? We know this
from simple psychology. Now there's an
American psychologist
psychologist named Julian James
and he proposes a really interesting
theory. His theory is actually what's
happening is the right hemisphere is
receiving information from the universe
vibrations from the universe and the
left hemisphere is interpreting this
information into reality.
Okay.
All right. So remember we we discussed
Kant. What what does Emanuel Khan say?
Emanuel Kant says that
there are two realities. The nomina the
world the things in themselves and the
phenomena the things to us.
Okay. So what happens is that our brain
interacts with the nomina and then
filters it back into the phenomena.
Okay. And it uses a filter time and
space
in order to perceive things. Okay.
Gu Hegel says that this nomenai is the
gist. Okay. The universe. And as we
discussed the universe are just
vibrations. Okay. Vibrations.
And so if you apply all this to this
theory, what's happening is our right
brain is receiving these vibrations and
then our left brain is just is
transforming these vibrations into
everyday reality. Okay. Then the
question then is how do we interpret
these vibrations? Well, for most of
human history, we've interpret them as
just gods and spirits.
Okay?
And even though it's not factual, it is
truthful in that it allows us to better
understand the universe and it better
allows us to understand ourselves. Okay?
By embracing this model
of the brain, we have access to wisdom.
Okay? The wisdom of Homer and the
Greeks. And that's why back then
the Greeks are much more creative and
wise than we are today. Okay, does that
make sense? Okay, because what we've
done today is we've shut off this part
by saying nope, all that matters is
science,
logic and materialism. Okay, so we've
shut down the right brain
and we only use left brain today. That's
why we are less creative.
Right? So that's the argument I will
make to you today. All right.
Let's continue.
All right. The great big bang the
beginning of Greek civilization. All
right. So this is Julian James. Okay.
and he wrote a book called the origin of
consciousness in the breakdown of the
bicchimeal brain. Okay, bicyal mind is
just the left and right hemisphere and
these two work together. The right is
the receiver of the universe. The left
is the interpreter of the universe.
All right. So he gives an example of
this. Okay. Why is it that in ancient
times when kings died, we buried them
with lots and lots of gifts. We bury
them as though they were still alive.
And the answer is from our perspective
they were still alive. Okay. The burial
of the important dead as if they still
lived is common to almost all these
ancient cultures whose architecture we
have just looked at. This practice has
no clear explanation except that their
voices were still being heard by the
living and were perhaps demanding such
accommodation. These dead kings propped
up on stones whose voices were
hallucinated by the living were the
first gods. Okay, does that make sense
to you?
We lived in a world where we're using
both our left and right hemispheres and
as such we saw spirits, dietes, gods all
around us. Okay, we interacted with them
and they gave us both inspiration as
well as motivation.
Okay, and so um this is a Viking
ship burial where a king is being buried
with his ship and his horses as though
he was still alive. Okay? Because from
their perspective, he's still alive.
He's still able to give us his wisdom.
This is the cult of the skull, which is
what we found in most Neolithic
cultures, okay? The most the earliest
agricultural societies. Why? because
they practice ancestor worship and they
believe that these skulls were living
and they could help you access the dead
in the spirit world and and and draw
wisdom and inspiration from them.
This is a book the constant serpent by
Jurian Narby. Okay. And he tells us that
listen, if you just do some basic
research, this understanding of the
universe where our right brain receives
spirits and left brain interprets it in
reality, it makes a lot of sense. Okay?
Because all the the entire universe is
itself consciousness.
Okay? It's all mind and matter is just
what we perceive.
I began my investigation with the
ignimma of plant communication. Okay?
plants are able to communicate with with
each other. We know the scientifically.
I went to accept the idea that
hallucinations could be a source of
verifiable information. Okay? So, if you
feel as though a spirit is talking to
you, maybe the spirit really is talking
to you. And I end up with a hypothesis
suggesting that a human mind can
communicate and defocalize consciousness
with the global network of DNA based
life. All this contradicts principles of
western knowledge. Okay. So all the
entire universe is consciousness. Plants
have it, animals have it, we have it.
And therefore, if we open our minds,
we're able to communicate with the
entire universe and draw insight.
All right? And he goes on,
scientists know this, and our greatest
discoveries came from scientists who
embraced the consciousness of the
universe. Many of science's central
ideas seem to come from beyond the
limits of rationalism. Renee Deart
dreams of an angel who explains the
basic principles of materialistic
rationalism to him. Albert Einstein
daydreams in a tram approaching another
and conceives the theory of relativity.
James Watson scribbles on a newspaper in
a train then rides his bicycle to reach
the conviction that DNA has the form of
a double helix. Okay, so it's almost as
though a spirit is telling the secrets
of the universe to the scientists.
So, and just ask yourself these
questions and you will understand that
maybe the universe is consciousness,
right? So, these questions are sometimes
you think of someone and then boom, that
person calls you. Is that strange? Has
that ever happened to you? Do you feel
as though you're being watched all the
time? Do you feel as though you're an
actor on a stage?
Do you sometimes feel you're compelled
to act as though something hasn't
control of your body? Okay. Possession.
Why do certain ideas pop in your head
all of a sudden? Do you sometimes feel
as though something planted an idea into
you? Why do you have dreams? Where do
dreams come from? What do dreams mean?
Do you sometimes feel as though you know
what someone else is thinking? Okay. Is
it possible you're sitting with a friend
and you know exactly what your friend is
thinking even though you're not talking?
Do you think sometimes that you're
having a conversation with a friend
inside your head? Okay, so your friend
is not there but you're having a
conversation with your friend. Do you
feel as though you have a guardian
angel? Okay, I'm sure you know you're
too shy to say this, but I'm sure that
you feel as though there is a spirit
world, right?
Okay, these were not mysteries and
questions before because everyone
assumed we lived alongside spirits,
angels, and demons. Okay,
today we ask these questions before they
didn't ask these questions because
everyone just assume that yeah, of
course, we live alongside angels and
demons and that's why we are who we are.
Okay. So, let's go to the Iliad. Okay.
And the Iliad, it shows us how the brain
worked at that time. A brain that was
both materialistic and spiritual. A a
brain that understood that we lived in
different dimensions. Okay? And the gods
had more control over us. And the gods
represented our emotions and the
workings of nature. Okay?
the Iliad. Now this is translation by
Robert Fagels.
So let's in the very beginning of the
Iliad okay Homer says this rage goddess
sing rage of Pilious son Achilles
murderers doom that caused Aens
countless losses hurling down to the
house of death so many sturdy souls
great fighter souls but made their
bodies carrying feast for the dogs and
birds and the will of Zeus was moving
toward its end. begin muse when the two
first broke in clash man on lord the man
and b achilles okay so the first thing
that a homer says is please inspire me
muse okay so what he's doing is not
creating what he's doing is channeling
he's drawing inspiration from the gods
okay when he's speaking to people he's
saying I am here as a messenger of the
gods this information is from the gods
themselves
All right. So, this is the fatal
meeting. Oh, sorry, not the fatal
meeting, the clash between Eggman and
Achilles. The first meeting that starts
off the Iliad. So, Eggman says to
Achilles, "Give me your slave girl and
get out of here." Okay. And and Achilles
is screw you. I'm not going to fight for
you again. And but now Achilles is
pissed off. He wants to kill Eggman.
Okay.
Eggman broke off and anguish gripped
Achilles. The heart in his rugged chest
was pounding, torn. Should he draw the
long sharp sword slung at his hip,
thrust through the ranks and kill a man
on now or check his rage and beat his
fury down? Okay, so he can't control
himself. Okay, rage has overtaken him.
He wants to like step forward and just
kill Eggman on
as his raging spirit veered back and
forth just as he drew his huge blade
from his sheath down from the vaulting
heaven swept Athena. Athena's here now.
Okay. Before Achilles,
the white armed goddess Hera sped her
down. Hera loved both men and cared for
both alike. Wearing behind him pelis
sees his fury here. Only Achilles saw
her. None of the other fighters. Struck
with wonder. He spun around. He knew her
at once. Okay. So Achilles is a
hallucinating Athena. No one else can
see her. Okay.
Pal palace Athena. The terrible blazing
of those eyes and his winged words went
flying. Why? Why now child of Zeus with
a shield of thunder? Why come now to
witness the outrage Agam Manonan just
comm committed? I tell you this and so
help me it's the truth. I he'll soon pay
for his arrogance with his life. So he
really wants to kill a man. Her gray
eyes clear. The goddess Athena answered
down from the skies I come to check your
rage. If only you will yield. The white
armed goddess hero spread me down. She
loves you both. She cares for you both
alike. Stop this fighting now. Don't lay
hand to sword. lash him with threats of
the price that he will face. And I tell
you this, I know it. It is the truth.
One day, glittering gifts will lie
before you three times over to pay for
all his outrage. Hold back now. Obey us
both. Okay.
So, Achilles wants to kill Amanon, but
now he's being possessed by Athena.
Okay. And Athena says, "Stop."
So, he she urged and a swift runner
complied at once. I must. When the two
of you had down commands, goddess, a man
submits, though his heart breaks with
fury. Better for him by far. If a man
obeys the gods, they're quick to hear
his prayers. And with that, Achilles
stayed his burly hand on a silver hilt
and slid the huge blade back in his
sheath. He would not fight the orders of
Athena. Okay, so again, this is not
factual. Athena doesn't really exist,
but it's truthful in that it gives us
insight into how the human brain, the
human emotions work. Okay. Now, what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to write
this again in modern pros to show you
the difference. Okay.
Okay. So, this is what what I wrote
myself. Okay. It's bad writing. It's
modern pros, but but you're able to
compare and contrast. Okay. I don't need
you. Get out of my sight. Roger man on.
He spat on the ground. Achilles blood
boiled and he reached for the hilt of
his sword. He saw all I stare at him and
he stayed focused on Eggman. He counted
the seconds and the steps it would take
for him to sprint forward and strike him
down. His feet grew heavy and his legs
grew wobbly. He could not move. He felt
the thumping of his heart. Achilles
snapped around and walked out of the
room. He saw all eyes focus on him.
Okay, so this is factual but it's not
truthful. Do you understand? It doesn't
give us insight into why this is
happening. So the Iliad is truthful but
not factual. modern pros is factual but
not truthful.
So now as I said Achilles refuses to
fight. The Greeks are losing the war and
so the Greeks beg Achilles to come
fight. Achilles says no. And he sends
Petroles to um figure out what's going
on. And Petroles comes out and says let
me fight Achilles.
Okay. And at this point, Achilles should
just be like, "We'll fight together or
don't go if it's too dangerous."
Instead, he says this. [snorts]
So he pleaded lost in his own great
innocence. Condemned to beg for his own
death and brutal doom. Okay, he is
Petroas. And move now to his deaths, the
famous runner cried, "No, no, my prince
Petroles, what are you saying?
Prophecies?" None that touch me, none I
know of. No doom my noble mother
revealed to me from Zeus. Just as
terrible pain that wounds me to the
quick. When one man attempts to plunder
a man his equal to commander a prize
exalting so in his own power that's a
pain that wounds me suffering such
humiliation that girl the sons of Akia
picked her as my prize and I sacked the
wall city one of my spear but right from
my grasp he tears her myon that son of
Atrus treated me like some veabond some
outcast stripped of all my rights so the
Greek army is about to destroy and
Achilles is concerned about his own
pride okay he's a very selfish person. I
man stole his girlfriend and he's
pissed.
Enough. Let bygones be bygones now. Done
is done. How on earth can a man rage on
forever? Still by God I said I would not
relax my anger. Not till the cries and
carnage reach my own ships. So you you
shot my my splendid armor on your back.
You lead our butterhungry Meridians into
action. And now in fact the black cloud
of the Trojans blast down on the ships
with full gale force. our backs to the
breaking surf but cling still to a
cramped strip of land the archives lost.
The whole city of Troy comes trembling
down on us, daring, wild. Why? They
cannot see the brown my helmet flash
before their eyes. Oh, they soon run for
their lives and choke the torn beds of
the field with all their corpse. If only
the mighty Amanon met with me with
respect. Okay, so the children are
attacking them because he's not in the
battlefield. But if you if you were on
the battlefield, the children would just
run away. Okay,
now as it is, they're fighting around
our camp. No spear rages now in the hand
of Damedes. Keen to save the Argos from
disaster. I can't even hear the battle
cry of Eggman on.
Break from his hated skull, but his man
killing Hector calling his soldiers on
his war cries crashing around me. Savage
cries of his children sweeping the whole
plane. Victors bring the archive armies
to their knees. Even so, Protis fight
disaster off the ships. Fling yourself
as children's full force before they gut
our holes with leaping fire and tear
away the beloved day of our return. But
take this command to heart. Obey to the
end. You can win great honor, great
glory for me in the eyes of all the
Argive ranks. And they they'll send her
back, my live and lovely girl, and top
it off with troves of glittering gifts.
Once you have whipped the enemy from the
fleet, you must come back. Even if Zeus,
the funding lord of Hera, let you cease
your glory. You must not burn for war
against these Trojans. Mad men lusting
for battle. Now about me. You will only
make my glory that much less. Okay. Me,
me, me. All cares about is me. Petolis,
you you can go a battle, but don't win
too much glory. Do not outshine me.
Okay. And because he says this, what
does Petus do? He tries to win all the
glory for himself. He engages in a duel
with Hector and he and it cost him his
life. Okay? So, it's Achilles fault this
is happening and he knows it. All right.
So, the psychology here is just so
insightful, so deep, so striking. So,
let's use an analogy to understand the
psychology. Okay,
let's pretend John and Jill are
boyfriend girlfriend, but they have a
fight like boyfriend and girlfriend do
and they break up. Okay, but they want
they long for each other, but they don't
want to apologize to each other. Okay,
so Jill tells her best friend Jane to
talk to John to try to get him to
apologize. All right, and then Jane goes
talks to John and John says, "You know
what? I've had it with Jill. I'd much
rather date you because you're more
beautiful and you're more, you know,
reasonable. And then Jason is really
excited because Jill is prettier than
she is, right? So she runs back to Jill
and says, "Hey, John asked me to go on a
date. Maybe I can use this opportunity
to convince him to apologize." And then
Jill says, "Okay, go date him, but what
if you do?
Don't kiss him." So what does Jill do?
Right? So this is reverse psychology,
right? Okay. So Jill knows that if she
says this, Jane's going to kiss John.
And Achilles knows that if he tells
Petus, "Don't win too much glory." But
is going to win a lot of glory, right?
And so what happens of course is that
Proacles dies now Achilles can now enter
the battlefield and win all the glory
for himself.
And that's what happens. Okay? He kills
Hector. He saves the Greeks. But then he
goes crazy.
What he does is he ties Hector to his
chariot and he starts riding around the
walls of Troy. It is a It is a war
crime. It's disgusting. It's hideous.
The children are going crazy. But the
Greeks are like, "We don't want this,
man." The gods are like, "What the
hell's going on?" Okay, so this is just
shocking.
It's it's it's a mutilation. It's
torture.
All right. So now we move to the end of
the Iliad and at this point Pry the king
cannot sleep because his son Hector is
being mutilated by Achilles. Achilles
can't sleep because he cannot forgive
himself for the death of Protalis. And
so he takes it out on Hector. Okay. And
the gods are watching this and they're
kind of disgusted. The games are over
now. The gathered army scattered. each
meant to his fashion and fighters turned
their minds of thoughts of food and the
sweet warm grip of sleep. But Achilles
kept on grieving for his friend, the
memory burning on and all subduing sleep
could not take him. But not now he
turned and twisted side to side. He lost
manhood, his gallant heart. What rough
campaigns they fought to an end
together. What hardships they had
suffered, cleaving their way through
wars of men and pounding waves at sea.
The memories flooded over him, live
tears flowing. And now he lied on his
side, now flat on his back, now face
down again. At least at last he leapt to
his feet, one in anguish, amish along
the surf and dawn on dawn. Okay, he
cannot sleep. He's depressed. Okay, he
is racked with self-guilt.
He cannot forgive himself for what has
happened. Flaming over the sea and shore
would find him pacing. Then he yoke his
racing team to the chur harness, lash
the corpse of Hector behind the car for
dragging and haul him three times round
the dead patrica's tomb. And then he
rest again in his tents and leave the
body sprawled face down in the dust. But
a poly pity Hector dead men though he
was and warded all corruption off from
Hector's corpse and around him head to
foot. The great god wrapped the golden
shield of storm so his skin would never
rip as Achilles dragged him on.
And so he kept on raging, shaming noble
Hector. But the gods in bliss looked
down and pity Prime son. They kept on
urging the sharpeyed giant killer Hermes
to go and steal the body. A plan that
pleased them all. But not Hera,
Prooseidon, or the girl with blazing
eyes. They clung to their deathless hate
of sacred Troy Prime and Prime's people.
Just as they had at first when Paris in
all his madness launched the war, he
offended Athena and Hera, both
goddesses.
But Zeus who marshes the storm clouds
warned his queen. Now Hera, don't fly
into such a rage at fellow gods. These
two can never attain the same degree of
honor. Still the immortals love Prince
Hector dearly. Best of all the mortals
born in Troy. So I loved him at least.
He never sinned with gifts to please my
heart. Never once did my altar lack its
share of victims. Wine caps tipped and a
deep smoky savior. These are the gifts
we claim. These are our rights. But as
for sealing courageous Hector's body, we
must abandon the idea and not a chance
in the world behind Achilles back. For
fetus is always there, his mother always
hovering near him night and day. So
would one of you gods call Thetus to my
presence so I can declare to her my
solemn sound decree. Achilles must
receive a ransom from King Pyam.
Achilles must give Hector's body back.
Okay, does that make sense? So the gods
are fighting over what to do. And then
Zeus says, "You know what? Let's just
poke over a piece between Achilles and
Pry." Okay, so Prime agrees to ransom
back Hector's body. and Achilles agrees.
Okay. So
again, we can write this in modern pros
and we can eliminate the gods. But what
you'll see is that it's not as powerful.
It's not as intriguing, not as truthful.
Prime cannot sleep and toss in his bed.
His wife and his children come one by
one to console the weeping king, but to
no avail. His servants try different
sleeping potions and one by one they
fail. In the middle of the night, he
screams at the moon and tears at his
graying hair. Prime aches for Hector and
feels guilt and remorse for failing his
son. Children spies watch Achilles drag
Hector's body day and night. They take
turns spying and they know that Achilles
cannot sleep. They report this news to
Prime and this gives him hope. He sends
an emissary to the Greek camp and
Agameanon agrees that is Prime's right
to ransom back his son as is a custom of
war. Even after the rage of Achilles,
Egameon sends a servant to talk of
Achilles. Achilles does not hear Prime's
offer, but he nods his head anyway.
Okay. So, it's less powerful. It's um
less truthful. It's less interesting.
Okay.
All right. Now comes the most powerful
part of the iliac. Okay. This is
actually when pry and achilles meet for
the first time. And so what happens is
that prime is snuck into the tent by
Hermes and the the majestic king of Troy
slip past the rest and kneeling down
beside Achilles claps his knees and kiss
his hands those terrible menkilling
hands that has slaughtered prime's many
sons in battle. So the king has
opportunity to kill Achilles but chooses
instead to kiss his hand and submit
before Achilles. And this submission
destroys the pride of Achilles.
Okay, it's a emotional battle duel
between Prime and Achilles. And the
Prime has won.
Awesome. As when the group of madness
seizes one who murders a man in his own
fatherland and flees abroad to foreign
shores to a wealthy noble host and a
sense of marvel runs through all who see
him. Soles Marvel beholding majestic
Pry. Okay, that's what Prime has done.
Prime is like a fugitive who's wanted
for murder. He escapes and he should be
a slave but somehow he's become wealthy.
Okay. So by submitting himself before
Achilles, Prime has changed the destiny
of the world.
His men marveled too, training startled
glances, but Prime prayed his heart out
to Achilles. Remember your own father,
great God like Achilles, as old as I am,
pass a threshold of deadly old age. Now
doubt the countrymen round about him
plague him now with no one there to
defend him beat away disaster. No one
but at least he hears you're still alive
and his old heart rejoices hopes rising
day by day to see his beloved son come
selling home from Troy.
Those words stir within Achilles a deep
desire to grieve for his own father.
Taking the old man's hand, he gently
moved him back and overpowered by
memory. Both men gave way to grief.
Prime wept freely for man killing Hector
probably encroaching before Achilles
feet as Achilles wept for himself. This
is the first time Achilles can now cry.
Okay, he cannot cry before.
Now for his father, now for Petraus once
again and they're sobbing roles and fell
through out the house. They forgiven
each other. Why? Because they love
their
people. Okay, so Prime saw Hector in the
face of Achilles. Achilles saw his
father in the face of pry and because of
their love for
others they found love for each other.
So love is the unifying force of the
universe. Love is what allows us to
forgive ourselves and forgive others.
Okay. And this is the tremendous insight
of the Iliad. Okay. And to demonstrate
to you how powerful this insight is,
let's run a scenario. Okay. Let's do a
thought experiment. Let's just say
you're driving a car with your wife and
your child home from restaurant, okay?
And you've had too much of drink and
then you hit a car and your wife and
your child died. Okay, that's the first
scenario. Second scenario is
you're driving home and then a drunk
driver hits you, killing your wife and
your child. It's not your fault, it's
drunk driver's fault. Okay, the third
scenario, you're arguing with your wife
and you're not really watching the road.
Okay, then that drunk driver hits you
and kills your wife and your child.
Okay, these are three different
scenarios, right? Let me ask you a
question. In which scenario are you less
likely to forgive the drunk driver?
One, two, or three? One, it's your
fault. Two is it's his fault. Three is
it's his fault, but it's also your
fault. Which one?
It's number three, guys. Okay? Why?
Because you cannot forgive yourself
first. All right? If you cannot forgive
yourself, you can't forgive others. And
guess what, guys? In real life, it's
always number three. It's almost never
number one or number two. So,
forgiveness is something that we
encounter every day. All right? Every
day we make mistakes and because we
can't forgive oursel, we can make even
more and more mistakes.
Okay? That's a problem of forgiveness.
And this is the deepest problem in human
society. And so, what the tells us is
that the real struggle is not for power.
The real struggle is within our heart.
The real struggle is between ourselves.
If we forgive ourselves,
we can change the world. Right? If we
forgive others, we make the world a
better place because prime forgave
Achilles. Achilles able to forgive
himself and they made the world a better
place. Okay, that's the power of the
human heart.
And this is what gives rise to Greek
civilization.
Okay, the Greeks engaged in an oral
tradition.
And in the oral tradition, they were
constantly trying to figure out the
mysteries of the human heart. All right?
So uh this is this is uh Pericles giving
his famous funeral oration. So every day
people are speaking because that's what
a person does speaks before others.
All right.
Um the Greeks were known for their
theater. This is the amphitheater in
Athens. You can see it seats about
10,000 people and this is what they do
for fun. They stage theater and everyone
watches it and the theater plays uh
plays byes is sopic or about the human
heart the mysteries of the human heart.
So every day people are thinking about
what it means to be human and that's and
that's why they have the greatest
civilization in the world. [snorts]
This is the agara the marketplace where
people come together and just debate
they talk. So Sakanish was famous for
being in the agara the marketplace and
just finding people to debate.
[clears throat]
This is the symposia. The symposia is a
gathering of wealthy people. What they
do is they drink wine and they talk
about philosophy, love, death, what's
meaning of life. Okay. Now, the wine is
interesting because they'll water down
the wine so it's not as strong, okay?
And they'll do this like for like the
entire night. This is Socrates engaging
in a symposium on love. That's what they
do for fun, guys.
This is a trial, Socrates. Um, so if
there's if if you're charged with a
crime, you face a trial and there's 500
people and you have to convince those
500 jurors why you're guilty or why
you're not guilty. Okay? All right. So,
this is an oral culture where every day
people are talking with each other and
that's the source of their creativity.
And what they're talking about is the
Ilia, the Odyssey. They're trying to
figure out what Homer meant, what Homer
was trying to tell the world in his
poetry.
Um, this is Heroditus. So even if you
write, the first thing you do is when
you write, you will recite your writings
to everyone. So you understand what the
reaction is. Okay? Writing comes from
community. It comes from understanding
the feelings of others. Okay. Today we
just write by ourselves and that's why
our writing is crap.
All right. So, um this is Anakarina Nina
considered the greatest novel of the
modern period. It's written by Leo Toy
Stoy and um it it's a really fun novel.
I highly recommend it. It's a great
book. Okay. And it starts off by saying
happy families are all alike. Every
unhappy family is unhappy in its own
way. Everything was in confusion. In the
Oblunksky's house, the wife had
discovered that the husband was carrying
on an intrigue with a French girl. Okay.
So, it starts over an affair. What
happened is that the husband's um um
sister Anarina will come from um St.
Petersburg to try to um resolve the
issue, but then she'll fall in love with
another man. Count Ronsky who and they
have an affair together. Okay. And this
affair destroys their families
and it ends with Anna Karina's suicide.
Okay. Because what's happening is that
she's demanding more and more Krosky and
he can't keep up. He's he's exhausted by
the demands of Anakarina. So this is
what she says before she kills herself.
My love keeps growing more passionate
and egoistic while his is waning and
waning and that's why we're drifting
apart. She went on musing and there's no
hope for it. He has everything for me
and I want him more and more to give
himself up to me entirely. He wants more
and more to get away from me. We walk to
meet each other up to the time of our
love and then we have been irresistibly
drifting in different directions.
There's no altering that. He tells me
I'm insanely jealous and I've told
myself that I am insanely jealous but
it's not true. I'm not jealous, but I am
unsatisfied.
I don't have any meaning in my life, and
I want this love to give me meaning.
Okay? So, it's almost like she's looking
for God. We've killed God, and now she's
looking for God in affairs, in sex, in
lust, and that's why she can't find it.
Okay. All right. So, what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take this and
translate it into heroic pros. Okay.
Let's see how Homer wrote this. I'm not
Homer, okay? But like this is how he
might have written it. Okay. And Aarina
went to the train station and sat on the
bench waiting for the train to come. Her
thoughts are empty and her head low.
Where do you plan to go? Someone asked
from the corner. That snapped Anna from
her trance and to her horror she saw
herself. But it was not herself. She was
older with graying hair and drooping
eyes. And Anna looked as though she had
seen a ghost. Okay, so she's
hallucinating herself 20 years from now.
All right. Who are you? you Anna shouted
in horror. "What do you want?" "Where
will you go?" the older Anna asked.
"Where's Watsky?" Anna shouted. She
looked around. The train station was
empty. "Okay,
"You know where he is?" the older Anna
said with a look of pity on her winkle
face. Anna got up and walked away. She
was being followed. So, she knows that
in time she'll just all be alone. Okay?
She sees her own future. "Anna, where
are you going?" the older Anna asked.
Stop following me, Anna shouted back,
picking up the pace. I am going to a
place where you can't find me. Don't do
anything rash, the older Anna said,
chasing after her. Leave me alone, Anna
shouted, and she ran and ran, screaming
and screaming. She tripped and fell into
the tracks right in front of the train.
So, and then she died. Okay,
so if you do it this way, it gives you
more insight into the human mind, the
human psyche, right?
And that's what what we've forgotten. So
what happens when we stop believing in
the spiritual? What happens when we
disconnect from the right hemisphere of
brain? We clutter our brains with
insignificant concerns, pursuits and
details in search of significance. When
we kill God, anything can be God. Okay.
So as I said, Anakarina with her fear,
she's looking for God. She's looking for
meaning. And before when we
hallucinated, when we talk with the
gods, we had meaning. We had wisdom. We
had significance. And now we've lost it.
And the result is what we call modern
literature which is complete utter crap
by the way. Okay. And we know because
this is Virginia Wolf to the Lighthouse.
Okay. It's considered the greatest one
of the greatest novels of the 20th
century. It's not very good. All right.
So this is um a woman talking to
herself. It's what we call stream of
consciousness. There were the eternal
problems suffering death. the poor.
There was always a woman dying of cancer
even here. And yet she had said to all
these children, "You shall go through
it." To eight people, she had said
relentlessly that. And the bill for the
greenhouse would be 50. For that reason,
knowing what was before then, love and
ambition, and being wed alone in Jerry
places, she had often the feeling, why
must they go up and lose it all? Okay,
so her mind is wondering, wonder and
wondering, and she's concerned about the
grocery bills. She's concerned about the
future. She's concerned about of the
past. There's no discipline. There's no
focus to any of her ideas. Okay? And
this is what we call stream of
consciousness. And it's the way we think
today. Okay. The reality is that we live
in a world in which God is dead. In
which we're not allowed to imagine a
spiritual world. Um and in a world in
which we're only focused on the here and
now. And as such we live meaningless,
insufficient lives. And as such, our
brains are just focused on things that
don't matter. Okay? And our brains
become schizophrenic.
All right?
Okay. Does that make sense, guys? Hey.
Yeah. Any questions? All right. Yeah.
Hi.
>> I I have a question about the
the concept about forgiveness that you
just mentioned uh that if you can't
forgive yourself, you can forgive
others. I think the example of this is
China and Japan because China hates
Japan because of the Japan invasion war.
And after hearing this quote, I think
China hates Japan so much even until
now. It is because that um China cannot
forgive himself because he's too weak.
And also just like the third third
situation that you just showed, Japan
base and China is too weak to fight
back. So uh China cannot forgive his
weakness. So uh he cannot forgive Japan.
>> Yeah. Um yeah, that's that that's a
great analogy. I I can I completely
agree. Yeah. Because if you're really
strong and confident, you just focus on
improving yourself. You don't think
about other people. Yeah. Okay. Any more
questions, guys?
But but thank you for the comment. Okay.
All right. So, last thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to read some YouTube
comments. Um so, I don't have time to
read YouTube comments, but my wife loves
reading YouTube comments and she sends
me YouTube comments and it's basically
my homework. Okay? So, if my wife sends
it to me, I I respond, right? So, let's
look at some YouTube comments from the
last video. Um, Wes andQatara says, "Hey
man, what about Africa? What about Egypt
and African civilization?" And you know,
I'm sure that Africa, Egypt, Sudan are
really, really interesting. I don't know
enough about it to comment on it. Okay.
So, what I want to do is later on I want
to focus more on Africa. Okay. Okay, I
want to go to Africa and I want to learn
more about continent so I can comment um
more about Africa. Like for me teaching
is a learning journey. Okay, I teach to
learn. Okay. Um so this uh YouTuber says
bad Bentham says um I underrepresent
livestock in the economic system and
this is absolutely true. Okay, if you
look at the steps the currency is
actually livestock. Cattle, sheep are
the main currency of the step people and
it's what allows the step people to
fight great wars because when they go
off in wars they can bring the livestock
with them and therefore they don't have
any logistical issues. Okay. So this
comment is absolutely right.
Um
question.
So capital changes ultra signic nature
to utarian when hard work and motivation
get saturated. Why are we only going in
one direction that's getting saturated?
Um
yeah, so this is interesting. So um we
have two natures, an altruistic and
utitarian nature. And what we've
discovered is that um if you break the
balance and you become too utilitarian,
it's almost impossible to move it back.
Okay? And that's why societies collapse.
How similar is this series to
civilization series? Okay. So the
comment is that I'm using a lot of
content that I used before in
civilization and yeah that that is that
is a fair criticism and the reason why
is that um what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to better understand history. So
what I'm doing is I'm trying to analyze
history from different angles. So last
year when I taught civilization, I was
trying to just figure out how
civilization work. And this year what
I'm trying to do is trying to apply the
idea of secret societies to the better
understanding of civilization. So I know
some of the content is repeating itself,
but the angle, the slant, the over
thesis has changed. Okay? And I'm and
I'm going over a lot of this information
in order to build a case of why we have
secret societies. All right?
um how do we manage to produce during
these horrible times? Same question I
asked myself yesterday. Okay. So, so the
question is what if children when things
are getting worse and worse and the
answer is because children is what gives
us hope. Children is what gives us
purpose. When you see that the world has
collapsed or when you see the world is
in chaos, you have children because
children give you the energy, the
motivation, inspiration to fight for a
better world. Okay? So I am probably the
most pessimistic person on planet earth.
Okay? I think the entire world is going
to hell. I have three kids. I have three
young kids. And the reason why is well,
first of all, I love my kids. I love
having children. but also my children
fill me with hope and energy
and power to fight for a better world.
I'm only doing this I'm only teaching
this class. I'm only putting this on
YouTube to build a legacy for my
children. If it were not for my
children, I would honestly not be doing
this. It's really hard work. Okay. All
right. So, that is it for today. Thank
you guys. Uh we'll continue next week.
Okay.